[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight a couple of hours ago
the Washington Post our hometown
newspaper here in the nation's capital
published an op-ed by former FBI
director Jim Comey in the Pisco me
explains that whatever surveillance the
Obama Justice Department conducted on
the 2016 Trump campaign was entirely
justified and within bounds nothing
weird about it at all
yes American citizens were monitored
electronically without their knowledge
but it wasn't spying of course it wasn't
spying it was investigating it was done
for your own good and if you don't like
it you're unpatriotic and possibly
mentally ill that's commis position what
the op-ed did not contain was any
evidence at all that what he said is
true
Comey is a bitter partisan with the long
history of shading the truth but he
suggests you've got to trust him anyway
it's your duty to trust him okay well
here's another idea we can see for
ourselves exactly what happened in 2016
we could declassify all the relevant
information and then make it public that
way we wouldn't have to take anyone's
word for what happened commis word
Trump's word anyone else's word the
president suggested doing just that
the left is outraged by the idea watch
Trump has every reason to believe bar
will use his new powers to aid the
president's anti deep state propaganda
efforts Trump giving bar a unilateral
authority over classification is just a
huge deal in the world of intelligence
agencies bar will be able to override
other agencies independent
classification determinations and the
goal of all this here seems pretty clear
it's basically to give sean hannity
material for his television show so the
plan as it appears now is essentially a
kind of purge of the ideologically
suspect members of the intelligence
apparatus it's a purge like joseph
stalin unless we stop the release of
business information people will die
that's what they're telling you just
other day of balance news coverage on
MSNBC keep in mind as you watch and
re-watch that clip that chris hayes is
not a flack for the CIA he's a member of
the national press corps but he isn't
arguing for openness just the opposite
hayes is arguing using
position as a public advocate to argue
against giving the public more
information these are not military
secrets by the way or the names of US
agents working undercover overseas the
information in question is about how the
FBI spied on Americans while
investigating crimes that we now know
did not occur so what could possibly be
the justification for keeping all of
that secret the details secret really
the only justification would be to
protect the Intel agencies from
embarrassment that's what they fear and
that's exactly why the former director
of the CIA John Brennan and so many
others are anxious to preserve the veil
of secrecy I think it's critically
important that the counterintelligence
professionals continue to carry out
their responsibilities and resist these
unwarranted and very very irresponsible
efforts to try to undermine what they're
doing
okay so John Brennan thinks it's risky
unwarranted very irresponsible to let
American citizens know whether their law
enforcement agencies abuse their power
that kind of transparency again is
irresponsible okay so what if we applied
the same standards to John but it
himself you know that after leaving the
White House Brennan was allowed to keep
his security clearance and that
clearance increased his value as an
employee once he entered the private
sector it allowed him among other things
access to classified information which
he could then selectively leaked to his
colleagues at MSNBC so how does giving
classified information to John Brennan
help American national security well it
doesn't it helps only John Brennan keep
in mind this is a man who's accused his
political enemies of treason a
death-penalty offense this is nothing
short of treasonous because it is a
betrayal of the nation he is giving aid
and comfort to the enemy treasonous is
defined as a betrayal of trust as well
as aiding abetting the enemy and so that
was the word that came to my mind that
was for the crime of holding a press
conference with Vladimir Putin last
summer in Finland he was talking about
the president what you just saw is not
stable behavior John Brennan is exactly
the sort of person who should not have a
security clearance close to a year ago
on this program we made that point
Brenden no longer works for the federal
government in any capacity he holds no
official post and yet according to two
sources we spoke to exclusively today
Brendon retains perhaps the most
valuable asset he had in government a
top-secret security clearance it is
terrifying to think that John Brennan
still has access to any of that
information Brennan is an out of the
closet extremist this is not a man who
should have a security clearance so
shortly after that aired the president
announced that he was revoking John
Brennan's security clearance that was as
we said almost a year ago it was July of
2018 what happened next well pretty much
nothing apparently as of tonight John
Brennan still has a security clearance
amazingly enough as he works for MSNBC
according to the New York Times the
president's order was quote hampered by
aides who slow rolled the president and
by Justice Department officials who
fought mr. Trump on it keep in mind that
Paul Ryan then the Speaker of the House
mocks to the idea publicly when Trump
said he was going to revoke Brendan's
security clearance according to the New
York Times the same thing happened with
documents that president wanted
Declassified the bureaucracy fought back
against the elected president and one
this seems to be happening a lot
recently according to Bob Woodward's
book on multiple occasions Gary Cohn the
National Economic Council director
prevented the president from pulling out
of a trade deal simply by stealing the
relevant order off his desk when he
wasn't looking
the president ordered troops out of
Syria last December you remember that
but that order has not been laid down
it's been delayed and mitigated again
and again now it looks like troops will
stay in Syria indefinitely in fact we're
now sending troops to the Middle East in
even larger numbers in directly
contravening the president's campaign
promises and as we just showed you the
same might happen with the president's
latest call for declassification John
Brennan among others is calling for the
bureaucracy to ignore the order think
about that like so many on the Left
Brennan is doing precisely what he
accuses others of doing you're
undermining democracy they scream even
as they work to do just that
how are they doing it well to recap
civics at its most basic level all
Authority and representative democracy
flows from voters the President and the
Vice President are the only
elected officials among the millions who
work in the executive branch of
government
if you subvert their policies ratified
by voters you are subverting democracy
itself brennan obviously knows that he
doesn't care but the rest of us should
care